[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
10 minutes 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 yes yes
yes
neither my check 2 1 2 3 4 thank you
like that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll see what what she says there but
there has been significant let's just
think we've been a couple members times
which will come out and question the
strategy Democrats only to quickly walk
back their remarks congressman Adam
Smith was the latest one here on the
house side Dianne Feinstein was totally
I saying a couple of slightly
differences about this at first saying
okay time for trial then saying actually
we trust Nancy Pelosi so clearly just
seems
well Holly this is a debate if a clearly
I want to be having a over here in the
house and you know I think I thought it
was interesting you had such angry
comments from lately and Rand Paul
coming out of that closed-door briefing
you know suggesting that the secretaries
of state and attention essentially said
you know it's better for the country at
large if there isn't a public debate on
more powers the house
good morning everyone today's a happy
day for us we are going to celebrate the
wedding of barbara Lee who got married
on New Year's Day or New Year's Eve I
guess it was in California but today was
celebrate her wedding in Washington DC I
convey that to you because it is a
source of joy to us as she is a source
of joy and in her service to the country
and her personal happiness is as lovely
in any event here we are get the eyes
and ear on impeachment oh let me start
with Iran today we will have a
resolution on the floor of put forth by
congresswoman at least the slot ELISA
Slavkin were very proud of her
experience in terms of national security
under Democratic and Republican
presidents now a member of Congress
putting forward the resolution of this
week last week in our view the president
the administration conducted a
provocative disproportionate air strike
against Iran which endangered Americans
and did so without consulting Congress
when I was informed of this attack that
administration took responsibility for
it over the weekend
I said why did you not consult with
Congress well we held it in closely we
held it in close closely no you have a
responsibility to consult with Congress
now we held it close so what whoever
close means as you see there has been
been some criticism from the Republicans
about the briefing that would that was
put forth yesterday by the
administration on this subject some have
asked do you agree that this is the
worst intelligence classified briefing
that Congress has received from this
administration as some of you heard me
say there's stiff competition for that
designation designation of worst so here
we are to protect American lives and
values we are passing today a War Powers
Resolution to limit the president
military actions the administration must
is to be escalate and must protect
prevent further violence America and the
world cannot afford war some of you've
heard me say that in December of the
bipartisan delegation to the 70th
anniversary of the Battle of the Bulge
it was just so remarkable to meet our
VIPs where our our veterans who served
at the Battle of the bow some of them
also at Normandy imagine the courage
teenagers most of them at the time but
the compelling message from the veterans
whose the veteran who spoke for them
along with the king of Belgium and the
Archduke of Luxembourg and the president
of Germany the veteran who spoke he
spoke about the better Band of Brothers
he spoke about allies working together
multilateralism he spoke about the
challenges they faced in those winters
reminding me really of Washington
Crossing the Delaware because it was in
December and was snowing and they were
not as prepared for snow and camouflage
from snow as they needed to be but just
seeing their patriotism their courage
those young people and this veteran
coming to speak for them 90 some years
old at the end of his remarks he said I
just wanted one message and I don't know
if it's appropriate to say but I will
pray for peace pray for peace that's
what we all do protecting the American
people is our first responsibility
protect and defend an oath we take not
only of our Constitution but of the
American people pray for peace that's
what we must do and so what happened in
the view of many of us is not a
promoting peace but an escalation not
that we have any confidence and the
goodness are the good intentions of Iran
and we certainly do not respect an act
from my intelligence background no
how bad sulemani was it's not because we
expect good things from them but we
expect great things from us now in terms
of impeachment you love keep asking me
the same question I keep giving you the
same answer as I said right from the
start we need to see that the arena in
which we are sending our managers is
that too much to ask in October we put
forth HR 660 which is has a resolution
which talked about the terms under which
we would proceed further to further
proceed with the investigation so that
people knew what the battlefield would
look like we expect to see that here
I've hear different things I hear that
they might want to you probably heard
one way or another some of them have
suggested they might want to dismiss
dismiss equals cover-up dismiss equals
admission that your fate of the facts
the truths the witnesses and the
documentation we would have hoped that
like as with the Clinton process that
there would have been a bipartisan
resolution determining how to proceed
contrary to what the majority leader
says he says this is like the Clinton no
it's not at all and I sent our members
yesterday six points in which it is six
of the points in which it is different
but nonetheless at some point we would
hope that we would see from them but the
terms of engagement will be we are ready
we are proud of our defense of the
Constitution of the United States we are
concerned that the Senators will not be
able to live up to the oath that they
must take to have an impartial trial so
much for that at the same time if this
is all going on it's important to note
that there's so many other things of
concern to the American people one is
the assault on the Affordable Care Act
that this administration is engaged in
in the courts and the Congress and we
are fighting them in the courts in the
Congress and in the country but right
now they are in the court instead of
defending the law of the land as is the
responsibility of the Justice Department
this administration is fighting the law
of the land
that means benefit for pre-existing
conditions no lifetime limits or annual
limits child staying on your policies
with 26 being a woman no longer being a
pre-existing condition the list goes on
and on that they want to tear down so
with all of the other shall we say
distractions going on which are a
collateral benefit to the administration
because it is a distraction as they are
masterful at of what's going on in
addition to that and relate it to health
is the statement from the administration
that they're no longer going to enforce
it NEPA the National Environmental
Protection Act
this means more polluters will be right
there next to the water supply of our
children that's a public health issue
that they're in and their denial of
climate they are going to not use the
climate issue as anything to do with
environmental decision-making public
should know this denial denial about the
climate crisis in the midst of forest
fires in Australia and we have them in
our own country and then I'll close by
just talking about I probably are the
work that our members have done for the
people we have moved to lower health
care costs by lowering the cost of
prescription drug hr3
wildly popular in the country hopefully
well but and passed the house before we
left we also were proud to pass the
mexico-us
us-mexico Canada trade agreement which
is sitting over in the Senate it's
sitting over there where
and maybe 400 bills we've sent over more
than 275 of them bipartisan legislation
one of them we observed yesterday the
ninth anniversary of the assault on
Gabby Giffords life is a bullet and I
wear that of the highest priority
because if they would pass this bill it
would save lives the bill to have
sensible background check legislation so
again we're proud of our legislative
agenda to lower health care cost keep
the American people safe build bigger
paychecks by building infrastructure and
this week this coming week in the next
period of time our Chairman led by Peter
DeFazio chairman DeFazio the
infrastructure and Transportation
Committee will be putting forth our most
current initiative initiative on a climb
on the young I say climate because you
can't do infrastructure without having a
recognition of resilience and and green
technologies so that's where we are
there now today we again send sad
condolences to the person who lost his
or her life in Puerto Rico others whose
homes were damaged we call upon the
White House to stop it's unlawful
withholding of funds from Puerto Rico we
also there's there needs that need to be
met there has been a disaster designated
but the ongoing withholding of funds
appropriated by Congress to Puerto Rico
is illegal and we call upon the
administration to cease and desist that
illegal activity so what else we have
here
maybe we'll just take some questions
from all of you
you say that you need to know what the
arena looks like yes in it how long are
you prepared to hold on to the articles
of impeachment if you don't get the
answers you're looking well it's
interesting just to listen to what they
say because they may not the other day
you probably heard the leader say I'm
glad to show you what it is when I'm
ready but we don't know when he's going
to be glad to be ready to show it to us
so there is something that they will
have and then he says well we'll pass it
once we get the the the articles in the
past a few weeks since we've had this
shall we say impasse because they won't
reveal the terms of engagement many
things have been accomplished that are
collateral benefit to the discussion and
they relate to on December 20th new
email showed that 91 minutes after
Trump's phone call with the Ukrainian
president a top OMB aid s DoD to hold
off on sending military aid to the
Ukraine directly related to that call on
December 29th was report public
revelations about Mulvaney's role in the
delay of the a the effort of lawyers at
OMB DOJ and what has to justify the
delay and the alarm that the delay
caused within the administration because
everyone was not in agreement last
Thursday newly unredacted pentagon
emails exposed serious concerns by
administration officials about the
legality of the president's hold on the
aid legality of the president's hold on
the UK to Ukraine just this week
Bolton announced that he would comply
with a subpoena compelling his testimony
his lawyers have stated he has new
relevant information these and other of
our investigation and our articles
necessitate a fair trial with documents
and witnesses they don't want documents
the documentation they don't want
witnesses
they may wanted to miss dismissal which
is proof that they cannot cannot clear
the president of the wrongdoing that she
has put forth no I'm not holding
indefinitely I'll send them over when
I'm ready and that will probably be soon
I don't you know you said if you don't
send them over I'm gonna pass the
mexico-us man can't hit a trade
agreement okay but no we we want to see
what they're willing to do and the
manner in which they will do it but we
will not let them say oh this is just
like Clinton's fair is here it's not
documents documentation witnesses facts
truth that's what they're afraid of
oh I thought you meant Mitch McConnell
okay I think we should move smartly and
strategically this is an h.con.res
concurrent resolution yes there's been
some criticism from both sides that this
should be binding I know there's some
parliamentary questions about it being
privileged over there but why not make
this with real teeth to make this like
an AUMF this is with real teeth if you
are familiar with the War Powers Act and
I'll get you the text the war Paris
attacks enables two approaches to go
forward one is a concurrent resolution
and it gives the procedure for that
which we will be following today and it
gives it come consult concurrent and
before H con resolution we're taking
this path because it does not require a
statement by the signature of the
President of the United States this is a
statement of the Congress of the United
States and I will not
have that statement be diminished by
whether the president will veto it or
not many of your members have raised
serious concerns about the timing of the
strike against Soleimani the
administration's justification you've
been briefed do you think that the
administration mislead the American
people about an imminent attack I think
that it's very unfortunate that right
now because I was briefed in the gang of
eight and I was briefed in the what did
he call it demeaning and at worst a
classified briefing that said the
Republican senators ever heard yesterday
so it's at this point in terms of what
is in the public domain difficult to
address some of what they contended
however I will save this because I was
informed by phone call as I mentioned to
earlier I think I did anyway that that
when I was briefed by the Secretary of
Defense and chairman of the Joint Chiefs
over the weekend taking responsibility
for them the killing that it was
disdainful in terms of not consulting
with Congress dismissive we had weak
held it closely really so if you want us
to all join together let us have a
strategy that we work together on I do
not believe in terms of what is in the
public domain that they have made the
country safer by what they did and that
is what our responsibility is we'll have
more discussion of this on the floor
today at some length but it's real
again as I go back to the Battle of the
Bulge pray for peace we must avoid war
and the cavalier attitude of this
administration it's it's stunning and
the President to say oh I inform you by
reading my tweets no that's not the
relationship that our founders had in
mind in the Constitution of the United
States when they gave power
to the present to the White House hope
to do one thing in terms of our national
security and to the Congress to declare
war and to allocate resources and the
rest so this is this is a your question
is an important one we again we will
have two hours that debate an hour on
the roll
two hours on the bill today to put forth
some a factual basis of our concern that
we have and let me just say this because
you hear the administration's say well
we were justified because the office of
legal counsel said the office of legal
counsel is a tool of the President of
the United States that's who that is
so whatever the president wants to do be
cleared legal his office of legal
counsel declares itself so it's it's
misleading to the public as to what War
Powers Act article two that gives the
president certain powers article one it
gives the House the Congress a certain
powers are there's a it's a it's a very
big issue now because it's nothing less
as we the I would spend a whole lot of
time telling them anything because I
don't know what their basis of judgment
is to receive information however I will
say this if they think that any
statement they make is there to curtail
public debate on the subject as serious
as this it just explains to you the
seriousness of the situation that we are
in we will debate on the floor of the
house now we are not going on the floor
talking about what we
learned in the and they said at the
beginning they said even if you've read
it in the newspaper if you here and here
you can't talk about it and then they
proceeded to tell us many things that we
have read and the local metropolitan
journals are seen on TV but that's
that's foolish
that's completely foolish and the as I
say we have no illusions about Iran no
illusions about soleimani it was a
terrible person did bad things but it's
not about how bad they are it's about
how good we are protecting the people in
a way that prevents war and does not
have us producing again and again
generations of veterans or suffering
because right let me just close by
saying this when we were there and I've
met many of these veterans at 70th
anniversary of Normandy when I met them
there I said no my uncle with him
rhoward sueb close to the Battle of the
Bulge they said well we went there next
and these were so brave teenagers mostly
they were in eighteen nineteen seventy
some seventeen years old and when we
talk to them this time because deeper
relationships over time they said you
know I never wanted to kill anybody I
didn't want to kill the Germans that was
incapacitating them I would chew them in
the leg or something and then one of
them told me I killed somebody and found
out later he was a doctor and I've
always carried that with me
I said well you were you were instructed
to shoot and get superior said you take
him I'll take him you know and they said
what he said well I still never forget
that so we all would die for our country
we take pride in saying that but to kill
for our country there's a pretty
traumatic thing so when we want to
engage in these whatever we want to call
this that the president engaged in have
to be really careful about how we
endanger our men and women in uniform
who courageously patriotically put
themselves out there to protect at end
of it any other questions
[Music]
because the airstrikes targeting general
Soleimani happened in Iraq is this time
for the house to consider a broader AUMF
I know that had something of the legal
justification the administration has put
forward with this airstrike is a time
for Congress to get rid of the 2001-2002
for sure well we did get rid of the AUMF
of 2002 and we it was in an
appropriations bill and it passed in a
bipartisan way and in the dark of night
that then speaker Ryan just took it out
it was highly unusual highly unusual
they just went and took it out I mean
that's that's ridiculous but that's what
he did so Congress has already passed
rejecting after it passed both houses
you took it out before it was signed so
we will have that resolution coming up
soon under leadership of congressman
barber Lee whose wedding we observe
today and the and then the question is
what do we do about an AUMF it's harder
than you would think because in AUMF so
who would who's president democrat or
republican how much power have
confidence do you have in that person
regardless of party to execute an AUMF
and the decisions that have to be made
about an AUMF it's important to know it
are what is the timing of it this one is
too long I didn't have it a date should
have a date not one that couldn't be
renewed but nonetheless it should have a
date the timing the geography what are
we talking about this was to go into a
rocket was used then to pursue al Qaeda
different places and and here we are and
and third what is the scope are we
talking about boots on the ground are we
talking about a recover what are we
talking about in terms of scope so
timing geography and scope when you have
that debate it's well I want the
president to have as much power or I
want the president not to have as much
power so it's
it's harder than you would think but we
have to do it and when we do it we have
to have it with enough time that is
realistic militarily
but also not endless so they're in a
situation that we're in now so to your
point the the argument would be made
that putting the shoe on the other foot
if the United States had a high-level
may be the second most important person
in the country assassinated wherever a
United States might consider that
assault on our country right and the
Iranians might as well even though this
took place at the Iraqi airport and so
it's it's foggy there are those who
think well it was in Iraq so it counts
but it was an assault on Iran so a
chilly count I don't think there's
anybody who thinks that that AUMF would
apply in Iran up to other point on it
though it is and that needs to be
addressed rewritten because we have to
have an authorization of use of military
force specific to through the danger
that we are are addressing one last
question
well they are in the Senate pants this
is the Senate of Chris Buescher and they
have tried to have a bipartisan approach
to how they would conduct the
investigation as again what are we
calling at the trial and connect the
trial but but feebly feebly the majority
leader has said this is just like
Clinton except it isn't it's exactly not
like Clinton and that he won't do a
bipartisan agreement on how to proceed
so that's very important but it is not
incidental to say what for the image
documentation and the witnesses now what
no separate from all of that under the
house Senate rules of 1986 what is
allowed for the presentation from the
house is one person to speak one person
to speak
so are those the terms is that what we
should be ready for or is there
something else that they have in mind
it's one person to speak for the house
and one person to speak for the White
House did you know that 1986 so is that
the rule under which they're going that
all we want to know is what are the
rules it doesn't mean we have to agree
to the rules but we have to like the
rules we just want to know what they are
so getting back to sports because that's
all we live right football football
college high school professional we send
in our team or do we have to send in
special team as well as the team because
we have to know what is but that trial
is about
oh yeah yeah they've had the negotiation
the senator has said she has doesn't
have to have witnesses and the rest
so that's but you know we may send them
over but what we have a I'm not
responsible to Mitch McConnell or
anybody else except my members and the
people who have worked so hard on this
members and staff patriotically honoring
the oath of office the Constitution of
the United States
and I would give them they're our best
shot to find the truth for our bosses
the American people thank you all very
much it would be my intention to go I
went I went um to the one game in San
Francisco
we watched all together the second game
in Seattle I have unfortunately
responsibilities to save our country
this weekend so I have my Democratic
wearing that hat of pulpit political
leader this weekend so my family will
enjoy our season tickets before the
Niner game and then next week well get
one game at a time and more San
Francisco Super Bowl well we've had the
ball tomorrow in San Francisco Superbook
and then that was hard because I had
been rooting for both teams all along
right and again going to the 49er games
and watching the Baltimore games on TV
right there above the stadium so what
happens they both win nobody was in a
more difficult situation than I then as
a mother of the coaches
father is coaching the teams and then
you saw what happened at that game
bought the D'Allesandro is from
Baltimore came all dressed in purple and
the Pelosi is from San Francisco all
came in red and we had a lovely family
reunion
this time I hope that it we've got a
similar result that we'd have North
James in there I already because of my
shall we say responsibilities to win the
house for the Democrats and hopefully
the electoral college for the American
people I was scheduled to be in Florida
that weekend so I'm all set one way or
another no we're talking about Tom Brady
who knows who knows what happens below
this but isn't it interesting and it's
wonderful because it's so unifying you
know everybody whatever your politics or
whatever forget it it's about the team
and we all like to say and we all
believe that we're all Team USA so
however it turns out Thank You long
that was amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]